do I sigh too much I got a comment and
one of my videos that Evan I love what
you have to say but you sigh a lot and
he's saying when I go like that it
bothers him and then other people jump
to my defense to say I like the side
makes it seem like everyone is really
into the videos and really cares last
week I had a meeting with with a buddy
of mine he's and entrepreneurs in video
production and he said Evan you know you
sigh a lot in your videos if I was
producing this we would cut them out as
part of our process and I'm really
intrigued by this because I don't I
don't intentionally sigh it's not it's
not done for staging or any reason
sometimes I get worked up sometimes I I
I care about you guys I want to see you
be successful I know how hard it is to
run a business and there's another side
and it frustrates me when I see people
going down the wrong path and when I see
them giving up when they have so much
potential and when they can really make
this thing go and I believe when you
want I want to see you reach your goal
and so it gets me worked up and I have
to remember to breathe in to calm down
and to you know tie the point home and
hopefully it has an impact on you guys
watching I don't want to be you know
this robotic guy who just answers a
question and doesn't show any passion or
emotion for what I'm doing because I
don't think that's gonna help so I'm
just being me I'm not I'm not doing this
for any Staging reason or anything else
just being me and I get worked up
sometime so that's my natural natural
response but I want to know what you
guys think I don't know if you think I
side too much if we should edit those
out or just let it run do you like the
sides do not like the size we're gonna
have a face off in the comments below
let me know what you think I'm gonna
judge see what comments come back and
make a decision from there thank you so
much vote and I'll see you soon